also very much in love Jennifer Lopez
they robbed put a ring on it last month
but today JLo revealed she wasn't always
so sure about their relationship when
did you know that he was the one that
you wanted to marry get married again
yeah I'm very weary okay I know I know
after everything that's you know I've
been through probably like a year in you
know cuz that's yeah we just sussing it
out and so they're I don't know maybe
yes maybe no I really love him I like
him you know what I mean like and we get
you know everything just seemed almost
too perfect too soon so it almost made
me a little more like eight Jill dropped
those details on Sirius XM's morning
mash up on hits one and has this to say
about that pink bikini pic turning heads
around the world
it's a look she'll sport in her new
movie hustlers I saw the pink bikini
anybody I have to get comfortable we're
doing stuff like that not that I haven't
always taken sexy pictures of stuff like
that but this is like a whole nother
level
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]